THE S WORST CORONAVIRUS
DAY IS THE FIFTH DAYH MORE
THAN 3,000D DEATHS I
WH 2N IS
E EXPERICE AND
SUFFE
DESPATD THE COMPLETE
S IS,
EVEN A IN TO
IN STRGL GIVE
F INTERNATIONAL  TTHOSE WHO
CORRESPONDA WARD ILIVE TO USI AT
U SAW ISEALLY UPSETTING.
>> Reporter: IREAKE.
N PRADESH ANE
SCENES WE W ARE HARD TO WATCH.
DO WANT TO WARN OUR VIEWERS.
THE FAMILIES WE SPOKE TO
TO SEE THEDY AND  THAT THEY ARE
>> Reporter: HAD A MAN WALES IN
AND WISH BUT NON
LISTENING.
HIJU A
HOSPITAL.
OH, MYHI
OH, ODINSIDE THE
S FING FORIS LIFE.
GASPING FOR,Y
CONVNG.
THERE ARE NORS ATTENDING
TO HIM.
THE HANDFUL OF STAFF
G INS WARD ARE
STRETCHED  THIS HOSPITAL IS COM
OVERWHELMED.DOSAY THATY HAVEOUSD
PATIENTS.TREATING MO THAN 10
YOU CAN SEE PEOPLE ARE LITERALLY
JUSTATELY HOPING
MEDID  HERE FOR FOUR DAYG
FOR OXYGEN THAT HAT COME.
I'M GETTING XIOU S SAYS.
IS LISTENING TO ME HERE.
ARU STRULI TEAUNABLE TO BREATHE
SHE TELLS US.
NONE IS TAKING CARE OF ME.
>> Reporte IOOM
MORE THAE PACK
IN TIGHTLY.WHATSETHTENSIVE CARE
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE TAKEN  THE
ROLE OF PRIMARY
MEDICAL STAFF ARE SIMPLY
UNAVAILABLE.
THIS MAN COMPLAINS NE WILL
CHANGE HIS WIFE'S SOILED
BEDDING.SUDDENLYS A LL SOMEONE .
HI, R-OLD RAJBALLA
APPEARS TOSLA DOCTORES IN D TELM
TO SDING HERND
FAMILY IS INCONSOLABLE.
WE'VE BEEN HERE FOX DAYS AND
ONLY TODAY WE GOT THE VENTILATR.
THE OX I
WE TO BRIN OXYGEN
IT'STORY WE HE AGA
EADING.
HIS WI'T GET A.
NO ONETO EVERYTHING,E SAYS.
P ME OR SHE WILL DIE.M T A DOCTO
I CAN'T HELP YOU.
ANR S US HE IS
STRUGGLING TO BRE
THEY WON'T LETERPOE HOSPITAL MI.
THIS MAN SS HIS WIFE IS DYING
OUTSIDE ANNE
HE INS ISN'T THE
PROBLEM BUT SAYS THEY ARE
Y SHORT OF.
OSO DO WORK HERE RISIENTS THEMS.
. OVE
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE?NOT WORRIED TO B
WORKING HERE?
YOU'RE NOT WNGROTECTIV
GEAR.
HO WEARING PROPER PPE,
THEY SAY, BUEVEN THE
DON'HAT D WE?
WE HEAR SCREAMS COMING FROM THE
ICU.
RAJBALLA HAS FLAT-LINEN D HER D
HER CHEST.A DOCTOR
HER PULSE, BUT IT'S TOO
LATE.
THIS TIME THERE IS NO POINT IN
BY SO MANYN  COUNTRY.
FAILED BY A HEALTH CARSYSTEM
ON THE O AND A
OMISMING THISRISIS.JUST A FEW A
VERY DFERE.
ORDERLS OF PEOPLE
TLY WAIT TO BE VACCI
FOLLOWING THE PRIME MINISTER
HA
CAN BE INOCULATED.
A STATWMAKER I0  GNGNE.E HOSPIT
BY TCA.
HOSPITAL
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: IT WASH
>> WHY. T WA
r:CONDD HERE INDIA HAS BEEN
HIT SO BADLY?E AR
ep HOSL
ADMINISTTO
WAM THATN  TOO MANY QUESTISIR, M
WHAT TO SAY.
HE'S TELLING HIMTO SAY.
>> WE ARE TRYING OUR B PROBLEMS
BU ARE TRYING.
>> Reporter: DO YOU ACCEPT THATT
PEOPLE?
>> NO, IS NO, NO
THIS CRISIS?
>> NO,O.
>> Reporter: I'VE BEEN TAL TO AD
TELL YOU PEOPLE ARE ANGRY.
>> THE SIT IT ONLY BAD
HERE.
HE SAYEASE THE NUMBER OF
BEDS AND WE'RE WORKINGTIRELED T.
BUT BACK IN E COVID  T
IME EFFORTS IS NOT
YET BEING FELT.ALLAH'S BODY IS
NEARLY BEFORE IT IS DERS MAY PR
TH EENTHS, BUT
THERATHE ENDF
THNNEL.
E , JAKE.
I MEANTAGES OF EVERYTHING.
SHORGES OF BED, SHORTAGES OF
PRONOUNCED AGES OF OXYGEN, BUT
SHOR TE  A SHORTAGE OF MEDICAL
PERSONNEL.
THE FIVE DOCTORS A NURSES WERE
RESPONSIBLE G AFTEE MORE THA0 P
IN THAT COVIRD, AND TODAY
OUT ANT THEY ARE MT
ACTUALLY GOING TO DRAFT IN STUDT
BACK FILL SOME OF THID AND
HELP TACKLTH CRISIS, BUTLISTEN.
IT'S GOING TO BE AN UPHILL , AN
>> THE LAWR YOU WERE SPEAKING,E
SAID THAT THEY ARE
AROUHEO HELP. THE FEEL IN
TERMS OF
IS DOINGK TH IS
BEINORTIVE?
>> Reporter:
>> WELL, IOBNDS
WHO YOU SPEAK TO, BUT THE PLACE
PEOPLE WE'VE BN TALKING
AND THE STORWE
HEG,PE DEEPLY DISTED
A REAL SENSE THAT THIS
CRISIS DIDN'T NEEDO
PRONOUNCED, QUITE AS AWFUL AS
HA BTAKEN, TT OTHER ASURESLD
PREPARATIONS COULD HAVE BEEN
MADE AND TT ESSENTIALLY
THERE'S BEEN SOME RENEIG
WE'RE SEEING A LOT MOROPLE
COME OUT A BE VOCALLY CRITICAL
OF P MR MODY ANDIS
E BJB.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THAMEHIS POLITIC.
HE'S STI